-Our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated
writer and comedian
you know from shows like
"Saturday night Live"
and "Detroiters."
The second season
of his fantastic show,
"I Think You Should Leave
with Tim Robinson,"
is streaming
globally on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-They're saying they want to
drop Corncob TV
because we showed over 400
naked dead bodies on our show,
"Coffin Flop."
[ Screaming ]
If you love Corncob TV shows
it's time to
tell Spectrum, "No."
They're saying "Coffin Flop"
is not a show.
[ Screaming ]
It's just hours and hours of
footage of real people
falling out of coffins
at funerals.
[ Screaming ]
There's no explanation.
Just body after body busting out
of [bleep] wood
and hitting pavement.
[ Screaming ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Tim Robinson.
Hey, Timmy. How you are, buddy
-Hey, Pal. How are you?
-I'm fantastic.
That continues to prove a poin
that I've said to people i
I will -- I have still
not stopped laughing
at "Coffin Flops."
I've seen -- I've watched it
10 times start to finish.
It never -- it never stops
getting funny -- being funny
-Oh, I appreciate that, pal.
Thank you so much.
-There was actually
a lovely article
where they interviewed
the stunt guys and
the directors of that sketch
because this really is the
audacity of sketch writers
that you and Zach Kanin,
your co-writer,
you write this sketch,
and then somebody
had to figure out
how to make the coffins flop
-Yeah. And the
hardest thing I had to do
was sitting in a white room an
just scream in the camera.
-Were there -- I heard there
was one coffin flop
that you wrote that they
couldn't figure out how to do.
-Well, not -- I don't want t
take credit away from them
'cause I bet if
we would have been like,
"Can we please try this?" --
But I think Zach and I
even were like,
"That's -- There's no way.
And it was --
The description was
"Person flops out of coffin,
rolls downhill, and hits a bird.
A bird that's standing."
It was -- And the line,
of course, was like,
"Yeah, some of them yard-sal
down a hill and hit birds.
But, yeah,
the hardest thing is, like
you don't want to hit a bird
and how do you get a bird
to stand there
with it's back turned
until it gets rolled into
by a corpse?
-Yeah. Do you distract
a bird with, like,
somebody has to hold a wor
so that the bird --
It doesn't hear
the coffin coming?
-Every time it starts to tur
around you're like, "No, no, no!
Looky, looky, look."
-Do you remember -- Mike O'Brien
has a wonderful cameo in this.
Do you remember the sketch
he wrote for "SNL"
which was he was
a reporter interviewing bugs
-Oh, yeah. Of course. Yeah
-And the same thing.
Like, again, it's that thing
where you're a writer,
you don't think about it,
and then they hire a guy
who, like, brings bugs.
-Yeah. That was --
Yeah, Zach and I wrote that.
-Oh, I forgot you wrote it
-Yeah, yeah.
Zach and I wrote that with him
And it was, like --
There was one bug there
that the bug handler was like --
He's like,
"Don't let that one get away
If that one gets away,
it could mess up
the entire New York City
ecosystem."
And we were
like, "What is that bug?
Put it away!"
-Like, how good an actor
is that bug
that it's worth risking it
-No. Not worth it.
You have to tell me this.
I don't want that bug around
-He's real good, though.
He'll hit a mark.
Never loses his light.
-We also found out --
On that thing, it was like -
The whole thing was like bugs --
Like, when you see them,
they're running or whatever,
and when it's cold,
they don't run.
-Which the guy, of course,
doesn't tell you
when you call up and hire him.
He just shows up on set.
-No, no.
"Do they run?"
"Oh, yeah, they run.
They run."
-You -- There's
a really great clip
of the stunt test on
"Coffin Flops."
And the thing I really like is
it's very matter of fact.
You just hear, like,
directors and stunt guys,
and they do a test, and
a body -- a stuntman falls out
and you just hear
the director say,
"Oh, this is gonna be
a funny sketch."
Like, you just have to
see it once to know,
oh, this is really
going to work.
-Yeah. I mean, it was
a whole day in the cemeter
of stunt people flopping out
of those things.
A whole day.
-You -- Another sketch
I want to ask about --
There's an action-movie trailer.
And the action star --
Crashmore?
Detective Crashmore --
Am I saying that...
And then you find out he's
being played by Santa Claus.
And Santa Claus as an acto
who doesn't like
to talk about being Santa Claus.
I'm doing this
a giant disservice
explaining it like this.
But I do want to stress
how good that actor is.
And I've told you before,
I obviously am happiest
when you are in the sketches
but this is a sketch
you're not in.
How happy were you when yo
found this guy to play Santa
-So, I mean, yeah,
he auditioned.
He was so fantastic,
such a good actor.
His name is Biff Wiff.
He really did
a really great job.
[ Laughter ]
-What is his name?
-Biff Wiff. I'm -- Yeah.
-No, I mean,
I feel like he -- I mean -
-I feel like he had the job on
the head shot at that point.
-Well, there's a lot of
Santas out there.
-Well, that's true.
-There's a lot of
Santas out there.
-When you're working off-season,
you're going to get
a lot of Santas coming in.
-Yeah, there's a ton of Santas
He wasn't the only person
who auditioned
who looked like Santa,
I'll tell you that.
-Really?
-No!
There's a lot of people
who look like Santa out there.
-I want to talk about
how the show --
Now it's like a recurring them
over the course of two seasons
that hot dogs are sort of the --
I would say hot dogs and fedoras
are the two images
I now think of the show.
The show has been
very meme-able.
This is a sketch, from Season 1,
a fantastic sketch,
about a hot-dog car
crashing into a store
and then this gentleman
trying to figure out who did it.
It's been used a lot,
like, politically
whenever a politician sort o
feigns sort of ignorance
as to how we got to this place
Do you ever think about
what a politician,
maybe an older politician,
must think
when someone is putting this
in their Twitter feed?
-I mean, yeah.
I think, in an article,
I mentioned that,
you know,
we had talked about it.
It was like, out of context,
that doesn't mean anything
It must --
I've forgot what article.
I wish I could cite them.
We talked about like,
"Well, if you see that,
you're just like, 'I have no
clue what any of this is.
It doesn't make any sense.'"
-I just like, yeah,
Mitch McConnell wondering like
"What is this supposed to mean?"
-That's exactly who
the article cited.
And it is like -- You would also
have to be like --
'Cause it's not
the first sketch.
You'd have to, like, go
five episodes in to be like,
"Where does this come up?
That guy..."
-Hey, I also want to
talk about the fact that you -
And I see this -- Anyone
who follows you on Instagram
would know this about you.
You're an accomplished -- I hope
that's a fair description --
an accomplished skateboarder
That you've been doing thi
for a long time.
-I wouldn't say
I'm accom-- I skate.
-Yeah.
-I'm not that good.
But I quit for a long time
and just started back up
in the past three years.
-And one of the
other things that happened -
you have -- Is your son 10 now
Is that how old he is?
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, he's 11 now.
He's about to turn 12.
-Okay.
And he started skating, as well.
-Did he find it via you
or did he find it on his own
-He found it -- I mean, I wa
skating, and then he started
But we live in -- You know
we live in California,
where, like, skating is huge
So I think that almost every--
A lot of people start skatin
who live here, so...
-Does he think you're cool
because you're a dad
who knows how to skate?
-No, not at all.
And, actually,
anytime I show him a clip,
he's like,
"You're going too slow.
You have to speed up.
It doesn't look good
if you're going that slow.
-When you show him
a clip of yourself?
-If I'm like,
"Oh, look what I got,"
and he's like,
"You got to get more speed."
-Do your kids --
You have a daughter, as well
Penny? Buster and Penny?
Is that right?
-That's right. Yep.
-Do they watch the show?
Like, do they like --
Does that comedy of
"I Think You Can Leave"
work for them?
-Well, it's "I Think
You Should Leave," Seth.
You said "Could."
-What is it?
-You said you were a fan!
What is this?!
-Look, I'm sorry that
you have like a five-word titl
that if I --
A title so long that, like
people write "I-T-Y-S-L."
-Okay, well,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
-Oh, are we using names?
Do names count?
Because then I'd like to add
"with Tim Robinson."
-Oh, that's not my name.
That's the title.
That's part of the title.
That's not my name.
That's not talking about me.
-Dude -- That's not
talking about you?
-No. That's just the name.
That's not talking about me.
-Of course
it's talking about you.
-It's not in reference to me
-It's your --
-It's not!
-Alright. Do your kids watch it?
[ Laughter ]
-No, they don't.
-Good. Good!
I have no sympathy for you
They're probably like,
"The title is too long!"
-Yeah.
-Buddy, again, I've texted
you so much about it.
It's so much fun.
It's everything I wanted
the second season to be.
Congratulations to you
and everybody who worked on it
-Thank you so much.
And I really appreciate it, pal.
I miss you.
-I miss you, too.
I'll see you soon.
The second season of
"I think You Should Leave"
is streaming globally
on Netflix.